من حي المنشيه في مخيم نور شمس شرقي الكرم
ينضم الينا مراسل الجزيره حسن مسعود حسان
ما الذي خلفته قوات الاحتلال في طول كرم
ازاء هذه العمليه
العسكريه الاحتلال خلف دمارا كبيرا واسعا
في مخيم نور شمس كما في عدد كبير من
مخيمات ومدن الضفه الغربيه خلال استك مال
مسلسل اقتحامات نحن الان هنا في حي
المنشيه الواقع عند
شرق مخيم نور شمس وهذا المخيم الذي شهد
خلال الليله الماضيه عمليه اجتياح واسعه
استمرت 10 ساعات متواصله نستطيع مشاهده
الاثر الكبير
لهذه التجريف وكذلك عمليات التخريب
والتفجير
للمنازل
واستهداف ايضا عدد من المنازل بمسيرات وهو
ما سنشاهده هنا من حجم الخراب كل ما نراه
هنا هو نموذج عن دمار كبير وخراب كبير
خلفته قوات الاحتلال خلال اقتحامها الواسع
لمخيم نور شمس الذي شهد مقاومه كبيره من
قبل المقاومين الفلسطينيين وادى الى اعطاب
احدى الاليات ايضا خلال هذا الا حام وهو
ما اضطر جيش الاحتلال لاستهداف المقاومين
في هذه المنطقه تحديدا ب
مسيره اطلقت صواريخها باتجاه هذه المنطقه
وهو ما ادى الى استشهاد احد الشبان نستطيع
مشاهد اثار هذا التدمير والتخريب في
المنطقه
وايضا نشاهد هذا المنزل هو منزل الشهداء
الذي ايضا يتم فيه الان
بيت الاجر لشهيد وحينما نتقدم اكثر الى
داخل المنطقه في حي المنشيه نستطيع كذلك
مشاهده اثر الدمار الكبير حيث ايضا يقام
منزل وبيت اجر
للشهيد هذا الدمار الذي نراه الان كله جرى
خلال هذه الليله فقط ليس بسبب اقتحامات
سابقه التي ايضا كان قد
شهدها المخيم عده مرات طيله هذه المرحله
وطي الايام الماضيه منذ السابع من اكتوبر
وحتى اليوم لكن هذا الاجتياح يعتبر من
الاقتحامات الاوسع التي كانت قد شاركت به
عدد كبير من الاليات و الجرافات ايضا
الاسرائيليه التي استخدمها جيش الاحتلال
لاقتحام المخيم لكن هذا الاقتحام الذي
استمر طيله هذه الساعات كان قد وجه بت جير
عدد كبير من العبوات محليه الصنع وكذلك
بالاشتباك المباشر الذي استمر طيله
الساعات العشر هنا في مخيم نور شمس
وادى الى هذه النتيجه قبل ان تنسحب قوات
الاحتلال